originally it began with a
feature-length screenplay that I was
trying to you know get off the ground
and it was largely based on experiences
that I'd had as a jazz drummer myself
with a with a very tough conductor and
an a very kind of cutthroat sort of
world a world that you know made music
feel like life or death to me and and so
I wrote this script and you know for
sort of obvious reasons had trouble
convincing people to finance a jazz
drummer movie and the the the idea
actually I was lucky enough to be to
find you know these producers in LA
Helen Estabrook and Cooper Samuelson who
worked with Jason Reitman and Jason Blum
and they and they it was really those
guys who had the idea to you know okay
let's see maybe maybe a way to actually
get access to financing for this is to
just take a scene from it and do it as a
sort of standalone short so we gave the
script to JK who very charitably signed
on for a short with no no guarantee that
it would lead to you know even a feature
and and so we shot the first kind of
extended rehearsal scene in the studio
band room or a entry was first kind of
inducted painfully into the into that
world and and we shot it and that kind
of helped get the ball rolling I mean it
was basically exactly year later that we
were shooting the feature with Myles and
JK and and it you know it also kind of
helped us get our feet wet a little bit
so Myles I had seen in his first movie
rabbit hole and it was came out around
the same time that I was writing the
first draft of the script actually and
so it really it's it's you know when you
see an actor kind of an actor you've
never seen before no one had seen it
before on screen before that movie just
arrived fully formed arrived as this
sort of I mean the fact that he to me he
just he became the heart and soul of
that movie and in a very small but
pivotal role not sameen you know and and
so I remember watching it and and kind
of immediately thinking I have to find
some way to work with him and certainly
he seemed to he seemed to pertain to the
role I was writing in the script the
role of Andrew you know a few years past
in terms of when it you know in terms of
revising the script then finding the
money doing the short so
there was a little bit of a circuitous
journey but I remember when I took the
short to Sun we took the short to
Sundance to kind of again help give it a
platform a miles was there that year
with the spectacular now which is
another wonderful film of his and and I
remember going to your QA at the Eccles
theater where we later premiered
whiplash sitting in the audience you
know silently planning my moves and it
works I got you got maybe audience
oh man you reeled me and so I was lucky
to you know I was in a way I was just
lucky that that you know when the script
did finally fall in my on Myles his lap
that he that he did it so he was someone
we kind of had in mind right from the
get-go and then Terry really once we had
these two guys it really became about
shaping the world around them and and
both with you know actors who I loved
like Paul Reiser and Melissa Benoist but
also real musicians was really important
to me that that most of the roles of you
know play most of the musicians in the
film be played by real musicians or real
music students and so that was its own
kind of casting process most of those
people had never been on screen before
and you know I wanted to do the film it
I just finished divergent and I think
from by the time that ended to when we
were starting it was like you know six
weeks so I think I took maybe like two
weeks just to kind of come back from
Chicago and unpack my stuff and then we
jumped right into the rehearsals which
for me was basically Damian knocking at
my door and with a drum set and I told
him I already had one but it was in
pieces and had dust all over so he
brought his shitty drum set we set it up
in my basement and you know just kind of
talked about music he gave me Raging
Bull and the movie control and said
these movies I'm ready to watch which I
did not you know I've seen Raging Bull
before it's a great movie you still have
my copy of control I think I gave it
back now he did not we'll discuss this
later semantics and so I gave yeah so we
did you know started playing jazz jazz
music and I had lessons three days a
week for about four hours a day and it
was tough because even though I have
played drums since I was fifteen and
I've played music my whole life
I was not I played saxophone in jazz
band and I had a little bit of you know
knowledge with that but for jazz
drumming I mean I felt especially once
Damian told me that I would I would be
the one playing you know these songs
whiplash and gave me the songs of
whiplash and gave me caravan and we you
know we plotted out exactly what
measures I had to know but for the most
part yeah you got to be familiar with
the whole song because just the way we
were shooting it a lot of time it was
either with playback or not with
playback but I was so scared to be
messing up in front of all these actual
musicians so life imitating art it was
just all a very authentic experience and
except for being terrified of JK because
he's such a softy but yeah I just
holding the stick you know traditionally
is such was such a weird feeling and
Damian and I have these beautiful you
know iPhone videos of my first few
rehearsals and I was just like I can't
do it I was like it feels just you know
just does this look good cuz I feel just
so stupid you know move around in and
slowly but surely kind of got to a place
where where I felt I felt I felt really
good movement moving around the kit we
actually we shot most of the day in in
Fletcher's apartment stuff with just me
home alone and and there were several
hints about you know what what his life
might have been you know at the time and
and prior to that and and and Damian in
His infinite wisdom decided not to use
any of that in the movie despite the
fact that we spent all that time
shooting it and and to leave to leave
Fletcher as a more mysterious character
and not investigate his backstory I I
don't I never actually had a specific
you know this is why this guy does what
he does other than what we sort of
established in that in that in those
scenes that we shot which was you know
this is a guy that that used to have
more of a life obviously with you know
as a talented musician has you know had
a you know who wanted to be a great jazz
musician is a very good jazz musician
piano player conductor but but
ultimately came to to realize that his
his purpose in life was was to find and
cultivate greatness and to and to find
somebody who had that potential and and
pull it out of them and and I've used
this before too but you know if pulling
that out if pulling greatness out of
somebody means pulling their internal
organs out of them at the same time
that's okay as long as I'm getting what
I want out of this person as long as I'm
getting absolutely the most at this that
this person has to possibly give I think
a lot of music sequences in movies these
days are from my money shot the wrong
way you know is it sort of that there's
the tendency these days is kind of
almost imported from reality TV where
you get musicians on the stage or
dancers or whatever you set up seven
cameras you roll them and then you
figure it out in the cutting room so it
was important to have a pre plan kind of
going in and then to have Tom's very
sort of acute sense of tempo and timing
and rhythm to make those cuts feel just
right not just be a transposition of
what had been kind of in the animatics
but really saying with the with the
music this film I said I think so many
people can relate to it because I think
we have all had have we all had that
teacher who really pushed us saw
something in us that we didn't see in
ourselves and I guess the question for
the group here if you can each just kind
of address it in your own weight is
there a limit when is enough enough and
it do the ends justify the means for
greatness who wants to start oh I'll
start because Damian should finish
because you know he's the one with the
brain up here frankly I mean I'm you
know I'm not saying anything
yeah it's true um I think UK as well I
think miles no I meant all of the people
directly involved in the making of the
film clearly yeah I I think as you said
most most of us have had a mentor a
teacher you know
was some kind of a version of this you
know pushing and pulling things out of
us for me the closest thing I had was a
couple of coaches in high school
football who were just you know over the
over the line by a great degree and I
had some some music teachers actually
who were very inspirational and who were
real perfectionists and and who demanded
a lot and and and directors in in both
in theater and and in television and
film but mostly in theater you know in
my very early days who you know who
would sort of see the bag of tricks that
I had learned and and and you know
appreciate it and see okay well this is
effective and that's working okay but
you know I'm not going to settle for
that you can do better you can do more I
need you to show me this this degree of
subtlety or or whatever it was they were
looking for as far as the end justifying
the means I you know I love that the
film inspires that debate and and that
the film doesn't answer that question
for us you know that there's an
ambiguity there at the end and people
take different things away from it my
personal take is I'd rather have a life
and a pretty girlfriend if I was Andrew
Neiman that that's that that's my take
on it very true yeah and you know
similarly I think in the way JK
performed it too you can kind of see any
gets that great you know monologue at
the jazz club at the end but you can you
can kind of understand the actual person
behind there and that it's not just
somebody yelling you know profanities
and vulgarities and and yeah because
that's boring and you've seen then
nobody nobody would give a [ __ ] about
that kind of that character and for me I
had a baseball coach that was just an
[ __ ] for the sake of being an [ __ ]
and I didn't like respect really what he
was talking about at that I think he was
all that informed with what he was
talking about and so that kind of went
in one ear out the other and then you
know I had a you know theater teacher
that was would kind of tear you down and
stuff but it with with that particular
teacher made me just want to you know
work work harder and and prepare more so
I think everybody's different I
learned as I get later on that yeah
maybe I like a little more you know
tough love whereas when I was a young
kid you know 16 17 maybe I was a little
more vulnerable and probably would have
got as they say on workaholics I got a
little butthurt about it I don't know if
it's the audience for your workaholics
but haha but yeah so I you know I think
it's whatever whatever makes you
whatever makes you makes me happy